dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir a glockenspiel
is a percussion instrument that consists
of small pieces of metal that are tuned
to emit a given musical note when they
are struck in order to achieve these
sounds this instrument is usually
manufactured as a set of metal bars
researchers at Harvard Columbia
University and MIT became interested in
designing a computer algorithm to obtain
different shapes that lead to the same
sounds and if it's possible that one
should be able to mill or 3d print these
shapes and see whether the computation
results are in line with reality
the algorithm takes an input material a
target shape and the location where we'd
like to strike it and the frequency
spectrum that describes the
characteristics of the sound we are
looking for furthermore the algorithm
also has to optimize how exactly the
stand of the piece looks like to make
sure that no valuable frequencies are
dampened here's an example to show how
impactful the design of this stand is
and how beautiful sustained the sound is
if it is well optimized you'll see a set
of input shapes specified by the user
that are tuned to standard musical notes
and below them the optimized shapes that
are as similar as possible but with the
constraint of emitting the correct sound
the question is how should the technique
change your target shape to match the
sound that you specified
one can also specify what overtones the
sound should have an overtone means that
besides the fundamental tone that we
play for SS on a guitar higher frequency
sounds are also emitted producing a
richer and more harmonious sound in this
example the metal piece will emit higher
octaves of the same note if you have a
keen ear for music you will hear and
appreciate the difference in the sounds
in summary with this technique one can
inexpensively create awesome custom-made
glockenspiels that have a comparable
sound quality to professionally
manufactured instruments staggering
results it seems that we are starting to
appear in the news it is really cool to
see that there is a hunger for knowing
more about science and research if you
liked this episode please help us
reaching more and more people and share
the series with your friends especially
with people who have nothing to do with
science thanks so much for watching and
I'll see you next time